Bonjour à tous ! Aujourd'hui une vidéo un petit peu particulière à l'occasion du premier anniversaire de la chaîne,
puisque le 11 Avril, ça fera très exactement un an que la chaîne du Précepteur est lancée.
À l'heure où je vous parle, vous êtes déjà plus de 16 000 abonnés sur cette chaîne.
Je tiens à vous REMERCIER du fond du cœur.
MERCI pour votre fidélité.
MERCI pour votre soutien.
Et je me suis dit qu'un an, c'était peut-être le bon moment
pour sortir une vidéo un petit peu non conventionnelle, par rapport à ce que j'ai l'habitude de proposer sur ma chaîne,
en l'occurrence une vidéo dans laquelle je voudrais un petit peu parler de ma personne.
Plus exactement de mon parcours et de mon rapport au travail, de mon expérience du travail,
puisqu'on est sur une chaîne de pédagogie dans laquelle j'essaie de valoriser la notion de travail.
Je pense que ça peut vous donner des clés de compréhension de ce que je propose sur ma chaîne,
si vous connaissez un petit peu plus mon parcours personnel. Donc, je vais me prêter à cet exercice, assez inhabituel,
dans lequel je ne suis pas spécialement à l'aise, qui est de vous parler de moi, tout simplement.
Mais dans un but bien précis, qui est de vous expliciter
ma conception du travail. Je vais partir de mes 18 ans, l'âge auquel j'ai obtenu mon bac. J'ai fait ma scolarité
au lycée Henri-IV à Béziers, j'ai obtenu mon bac à 18 ans en 2004,
c'était un bac littéraire,
et après ce bac, j'ai démarré mes études de philosophie à Montpellier, et c'est aussi l'année où j'ai commencé à travailler.
Alors, mon premier travail, mon premier "job d'été", comme on dit,
c'était déménageur. J'ai commencé par faire des déménagements, quand j'avais 18 ans,
un petit peu de manière accidentelle, c'est-à-dire que je traînais avec un vieil ami, que je connais depuis la maternelle,
et puis il me dit un jour qu'il décide d'aller s'inscrire dans une agence d'intérim
pour gagner un petit peu d'argent pendant l'été.
Et à ce moment-là, je ne savais même pas ce que c'était l'intérim
pour tout vous dire, je partais de loin.
Et je me suis dit : "Bah écoute, je vais t'accompagner et puis je vais en profiter pour m'inscrire moi-aussi".
Résultat des courses, on se retrouve à s'inscrire dans plusieurs agences d'intérim, et puis
mon été se passe, je continue un petit peu à profiter de la plage...
Et puis un beau matin, alors que j'étais en train de dormir, je reçois un coup de téléphone.
C'était l'agence d'intérim qui m'appelait pour me dire : "On a une mission à vous proposer". Alors à l'époque, pour moi, une mission
c'était une mission d'agent secret, je me suis dit
"Ils m'ont pris pour James Bond, qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire ?". Et en fait, non !
Une "mission", c'est tout simplement le nom qu'on donne à un emploi temporaire en intérim.
Et donc, comme à cette époque-là je n'avais aucun diplôme, à part le bac bien sûr,
ils m'ont proposé des métiers manuels. Donc le premier emploi que j'ai occupé, c'était déménageur. À ce moment là, je suis
sorti de mon lit en précipitation, je me suis habillé, j'ai pris le bus,
et je me suis rendu directement à l'adresse où avait lieu le déménagement, je me suis présenté et puis
j'ai fait ma première journée de travail...
je crois qu'on était en juillet ou en août 2004.
Je savais que j'allais faire des études de philosophie à la rentrée de septembre
et j'étais très à l'aise dans ce domaine là, c'est-à-dire que j'ai toujours aimé
réfléchir, me poser des problèmes, tenter de les résoudre...
D'ailleurs, j'aimais autant la philosophie que les mathématiques, parce que les mathématiques ça reste de la résolution de problèmes.
Et pour autant, je n'ai jamais eu de rejet vis-à-vis des activités manuelles. J'ai toujours été très sportif.
Mon modèle quand j'étais enfant, c'était Rocky, c'était Sylvester Stallone,
j'adorais Dragon Ball, j'adorais les films d'action, j'adorais le sport, la boxe, la musculation...
Et pour moi, c'était totalement
stupide, totalement inepte, de séparer le corps et l'esprit.
Le travail manuel ne m'a jamais fait peur.
Et quand j'ai expérimenté
le travail manuel, par cet emploi de déménageur,
je me suis rendu compte, que j'étais bon : j'ai reçu des félicitations
de la part de mes collègues de travail, de la part du patron de l'entreprise
dans laquelle j'ai été envoyé.
Et donc, cette agence d'intérim a eu de très bons retours de mon travail
et finalement, je me suis aperçu à ce moment-là que
j'étais capable,
par mon travail et par une certaine exigence de qualité dans mon travail,
j'étais capable
d'obtenir une forme de reconnaissance
que je ne soupçonnais pas, parce que j'étais surtout, à l'époque, reconnu pour mes bons résultats
scolaires, et ça, c'est quelque chose que j'ai vécu
de manière très valorisante. Lorsqu'on a 18 ans, qu'on commence à travailler de ses mains,
qu'on touche son premier salaire et qu'en plus de ça, on reçoit des félicitations,
je peux vous dire que c'est très structurant en fait, c'est très valorisant
pour l'estime de soi, et c'est à ce moment-là qu'on commence à se sentir
devenir adulte. C'est vraiment un rite initiatique,
et c'est pour ça que si vous avez des enfants
qui sont en âge de travailler, et on est en âge de travailler à partir de 16 ans en France aujourd'hui,
je vous encourage à les mettre au travail, en fait.
Sans forcément leur demander leur avis, tout simplement en leur disant :
"Dorénavant,
si tu veux de l'argent de poche, cet argent de poche, tu vas aller le gagner toi-même,
par le travail de tes mains, par la sueur de ton front".
Et je peux vous assurer qu'en faisant ça, vous allez leur rendre un très grand service. Parce que vous allez leur donner la possibilité
d'être fiers d'eux-mêmes,
de gagner une confiance en soi
qu'on ne peut pas obtenir autrement. J'ai donc fait ma mission pendant quelques semaines, en tant que déménageur,
et puis à la fin de l'été, au mois d'août,
je reçois une nouvelle proposition de mon agence d'intérim. Cette fois-ci, il s'agissait de travailler dans une grande surface :
l'enseigne Auchan, pour ne pas la nommer,
l'hypermarché Auchan à Béziers. Et donc là, on me propose une mission d'une semaine,
avec pour horaire : minuit - 9h du matin.
J'ai dis "Pas de problème, je prends !".
J'avais déjà mis un pied dans le travail,
je peux vous dire que déménageur, en plein été, dans le sud de la France,
vous le sentez passer. Si vous êtes capable de faire ça, vous êtes capable de travailler dans un magasin climatisé,
quand bien même ce serait de minuit à 9 heures du matin, il n'y a pas de problème ! Donc,
je commence ce nouvel emploi,
et puis là encore,
je fais du bon travail. C'est-à-dire que quand j'arrive dans l'entreprise,
j'arrive avec une forme d'humilité, j'étais même assez intimidé pour tout vous dire, c'est-à-dire qu'à 18 ans,
ont fait pas le "fifou" quand on arrive dans une grande entreprise, qui
fonctionne avec plus de 250 employés, avec des gens qui sont hyper rodés,
qui ont un sens de l'organisation à toute épreuve... Je peux vous dire que vous avez intérêt à être observateur, vous avez intérêt à être
attentif, à l'écoute des consignes, des directives, et que là encore, si vous faites du mauvais boulot,
vous pouvez être sûr qu'une fois que votre chef aura signé le relevé d'heures,
on ne vous rappellera pas. Donc vous êtes obligé de vous accrocher, vous êtes obligé de montrer que vous en voulez,
et là encore, si vous faites du bon boulot, on sera très heureux de vous garder. Mes employeurs ont été
satisfaits du travail que j'ai fait et c'est là que j'ai commencé, vraiment, à rentrer dans la machine en me disant :
"On est capable finalement, quand on s'en donne les moyens, quand on a suffisamment de volonté, on est capable d'obtenir cette reconnaissance professionnelle",
dont on nous dit souvent qu'elle dépend du bon vouloir de l'employeur, du bon vouloir du patron. C'est vrai dans certains cas,
mais dans ce qui est du travail manuel, manutentionnaire,
je peux vous dire, que c'est vraiment au mérite, c'est vraiment à l'effort que ça se joue, et en tout cas, c'est
comme ça que ça s'est passé pour moi et donc c'est comme ça que j'ai entamé mon expérience
du travail manuel. L'été se termine, je m'inscris à la fac
de lettres de Montpellier : l'Université Paul-Valéry, en philosophie.
Et j'alterne entre
des moments où je vais à la fac, alors j'habitais encore à Béziers, du coup je prenais le train tous les matins
jusqu'à Montpellier, il y a à peu près 70 km, donc en tout j'en avais pour une heure de trajet à partir du moment où
je partais de la gare de Béziers et au moment où j'arrivais à la fac
il s'écoulait à peu près une heure. Donc j'avais une heure de trajet, aller et retour,
je passais ma journée à la fac,
je suivais mes cours, enfin, ma journée... C'est une façon de parler, parce que je peux vous dire que licence de philosophie
et licence universitaire, en général, vous n'avez pas 40 heures de cours par semaine.
On avait à peu près une vingtaine d'heures de cours, grand maximum.
Et...
donc ce n'était pas,
d'un poids totalement écrasant, c'était totalement supportable. Et donc,
je me suis inscrit dans une espèce de routine
où je me levais le matin, je prenais mon train, j'allais à la fac, je rentrais le soir.
Et le soir, j'allais travailler à Auchan, je faisais mes heures, je gagnais un petit peu d'argent comme ça.
Et je me suis rendu compte qu'il était totalement possible, dès l'âge de 18 ans, de prendre son indépendance financière,
à condition de s'en donner les moyens.
Alors j'étais boursier à l'université, c'est-à-dire que je touchais une allocation, d'environ
350 € par mois, si je me souviens bien,
la bourse est toujours calculée sur les revenus des parents, et comme mes parents n'étaient pas imposables,
ils gagnaient assez peu d'argent, j'ai bénéficié de cette bourse universitaire. Et comme je n'avais pas de logement, universitaire,
j'habitais encore chez mes parents pendant ma première année de fac,
je n'avais pas de loyer à payer. Du coup, je gagnais à peu près 400 - 500 € par mon travail,
plus 350 € de bourse et je payais, je crois, 90 € par mois pour le train.
Donc au final, je pouvais me dégager un petit salaire
qui me permettait finalement de prendre en charge mes propres dépenses. J'étais animé d'un désir
vraiment vif, vraiment profond, de prendre cette indépendance,
ça a toujours été ma manière de fonctionner.
J'ai toujours
mis un point d'honneur à ne pas dépendre des autres, à ne pas dépendre de la charité, pour
employer un grand mot, des autres.
Et c'est pour ça que j'ai toujours travaillé depuis mes 18 ans et que je n'ai jamais eu
à me laisser porter, parce que j'avais des parents qui m'auraient payé un appartement, ou qui auraient
payé mes études, ou qui m'auraient donné de l'argent de poche. Je trouve ça très bien que des parents puissent aider leurs enfants à
suivre leurs études dans de bonnes conditions,
mais il y a un revers de la médaille, c'est que quand on fait ça, l'enfant qui devient adulte,
devient adulte par l'âge, mais ne devient pas adulte par le vécu, ne devient pas adulte par la pratique.
Et devenir adulte, c'est
travailler, c'est gagner son argent,
c'est se lever le matin en se disant que si on ne se lève pas, on ne sera pas payé, et si on n'est pas payé,
on ne peut pas bouffer. Je dis souvent que
"la réalité, c'est ce qu'on assume", et on ne peut pas ne pas l'assumer, la réalité. Parce qu'on aura beau dire
tout ce qu'on voudra,
si on n'a rien dans le frigo, on ne peut rien faire. Vous voyez ? Donc à partir de là,
il n'y a pas cinquante solutions, c'est soit on se démerde pour survivre, soit on trouve d'autres solutions, mais
généralement ces solutions-là ne sont pas pérennes.
Pendant des années, j'ai suivi ce rythme, au point que
la plupart de mes collègues de travail ne savaient même pas que j'étais étudiant. Ils pensaient que j'étais un
employé, un salarié comme eux, à plein temps, parce que
le vendredi et le samedi, je passais tellement d'heures dans l'entreprise que je connaissais tout le personnel,
et certains ne se rendaient même pas compte que la semaine je n'étais pas là. Donc c'était assez drôle
et puis, là aussi, c'était assez valorisant de se considérer comme un membre à part entière
d'une équipe. Parce que ce qu'il faut pas oublier, c'est que quand vous travaillez dans une grande entreprise,
vous créez des relations, vous créez même des amitiés avec vos collègues de travail,
et vous apprenez à découvrir d'autres manières de penser que la vôtre. À 18 ans on ne connaît pas grand chose de la vie,
et quand vous passez
20 minutes de pause à boire votre café, à fumer votre cigarette
avec une caissière qui est là depuis 20 ans, ou avec un employé qui est là depuis 30 ans
et qui vous raconte un petit peu sa vie, je peux vous dire que ça vous instruit, que vous apprenez beaucoup de choses.
Et à ce moment-là, vous voyez autrement ce que vous apprenez quand vous êtes à la fac.
Et moi, ce que je peux vous dire, c'est que quand j'étais à la fac de philo à Montpellier,
les étudiants avec qui j'étais en cours,
je les avais en horreur. ils m'insupportaient au plus haut point, parce que j'entendais des gamins de 20 ans
me parler de révolution, me parler de prolétariat, me parler de justice...
des mots plein la gueule,
mais sans aucune consistance, des mots creux, des coquilles vides.
Et je me disais : "Mais ces personnes-là,
si on les met dans les conditions de travail, qui étaient les miennes à l'époque, elles ne tiendraient même pas une semaine".
Des personnes qui
savaient tout mieux que tout le monde, qui avaient tout fait, avaient tout compris,
et
un mépris social
inconscient, inassumé, mais débordant. C'est-à-dire que
le prolétariat, pour eux, c'était un concept, mais derrière ce concept, eux, ce qu'ils voyaient, c'était la populace,
c'était la plèbe, c'étaient les gens
qui vont au bistrot pour jouer au PMU... Il y avait beaucoup de mépris dans ces paroles,
comme par exemple, lorsqu'on entend dire "Ça, c'est le discours café du commerce" ;
c'est-à-dire "c'est les prolos alcoolos qui parlent comme ça". Vous voyez, le genre d'expression qu'on entend...
Le problème, c'est que ces prolos, pour les avoir côtoyés pendant dix ans, parce que j'ai travaillé en entreprise pendant dix ans,
je peux vous dire qu'ils dégagent infiniment plus de sagesse, ils dégagent infiniment plus de bon sens, et de compréhension du réel,
que des petits cons de 20 ans, qui ont fait 6 mois d'études et qui pensent tout savoir et tout connaître.
Donc je vous passe
certaines situations et certains "clashs" que j'ai pu avoir avec des étudiants, je vous en parlerai peut-être
dans une autre vidéo, si jamais vous en faites la demande,
mais en attendant j'ai tiré toutes mes études
en adoptant ce schéma :
la fac la semaine,
le travail le week-end et les vacances scolaires, c'est-à-dire que pour beaucoup de gens, être étudiant, c'est être en vacances permanentes.
Mais je peux vous assurer que pendant toutes mes années de fac,
je n'ai pas eu une semaine de vacances,
parce que lorsque j'avais des vacances scolaires,
j'allais travailler à plein temps. Pendant l'été, je travaillais à plein temps de fin mai, parce que les cours finissaient fin mai,
jusqu'à fin septembre.
Ça m'est même arrivé
de continuer à travailler à plein temps
alors que les cours avaient déjà repris. Donc il y avait des cours auxquels je n'assistais pas, je demandais à mes collègues de fac
d'enregistrer le cours pour que je puisse le réécouter dans la voiture,
pour pouvoir passer mon partiel en fin de semestre.
Vous voyez ? Alors évidemment, je ne suis pas en train de faire du misérabilisme, vous entendez bien dans ma manière de vous raconter mon histoire
qu'il n'y a aucun ressentiment, au contraire, je me dis que ça a été une chance à posteriori, ça a été une chance
de vivre cette vie de travail, de vivre cette vie de contraintes, qui m'a mis du plomb dans la tête,
et qui m'a fait comprendre à quel point
le travail était un outil d'émancipation
personnel, de développement personnel, dans le sens noble du terme. Oui ! Le travail est une contrainte, le travail est une obligation,
et je suis assez d'accord avec ceux qui disent que le but ultime de la vie, c'est de pouvoir arrêter de travailler.
Alors plus exactement, je dirais que c'est de pouvoir choisir son travail, en réalité, parce que
j'en ai parlé dans un live que j'ai fait récemment,
ma définition de la réussite c'est
"vivre de sa passion",
c'est réussir à faire coïncider
son désir et la contrainte : la contrainte du travail, la contrainte de se nourrir,
avec l'accomplissement de soi par sa passion.
Mais je maintiens que le travail reste la meilleure école de la vie et
cette école, j'y suis resté pendant 10 ans.
Alors comment ça s'est passé ? Et bien, au bout de ma première année j'ai obtenu ma première année de licence.
Et...
pendant l'été qui a suivi, j'ai travaillé à Auchan à Béziers
pendant 5 mois d'affilés à plein temps.
Et là, j''ai rencontré une demoiselle, qui est devenue ma petite amie,
qui elle aussi,
travaillait en même temps qu'elle faisait ses études de biologie,
et à la rentrée,
elle faisait ses études comme moi à Montpellier, on s'est assez rapidement installé sous le même toit
et on a vécu ensemble pendant 6 ans et demi.
6 ans et demi pendant lesquels,
pendant mes études, parce que je suis allé jusqu'au niveau doctorat,
j'ai suivi ma licence, mon master, le début de mon doctorat,
tout en continuant à travailler en parallèle dans cette même entreprise. L'été je travaillais de nuit, je travaillais
de 3 heures à 11 heures du matin.
Donc je peux vous dire que
les premières fois ça fait drôle de se lever à 2 heures du matin,
l'heure à laquelle je me couchais habituellement,
là on se lève à 2 heures du matin, je peux vous dire que
votre corps ne comprend pas ce qui se passe,
et je peux vous assurer que quand vous avez fait 5 ans, 6 ans de travail de nuit,
que vous entendez des gens se plaindre
parce qu'ils ont 18 heures de cours par semaine,
ça vous fait rigoler. Ça vous fait rigoler... en fait non !
Ça vous énerve, ça vous met en colère,
et vous avez juste envie de leur retourner une bonne tarte dans la tronche
pour leur faire comprendre la chance qu'ils ont, la chance dont ils n'ont pas conscience, en fait.
Et c'est ça le drame ! C'est que quelqu'un qui grandit
sans avoir une expérience du travail pénible ne sait pas ce que c'est que le travail.
Et ça crée des individus, non seulement inconscients de la réalité du travail, mais ça crée des individus
capricieux,
prétentieux, paresseux...
pour qui le moindre effort est vécu comme quelque chose d'insupportable et d'insoutenable.
Ça crée des personnes qui n'ont pas d'auto-discipline.
J'ai souvent dit que le service militaire est quelque chose à quoi j'étais content de pouvoir échapper,
et avec le recul, je me dis que le service militaire est quelque chose qui aurait pu accélérer ce processus
d'auto-discipline, que j'ai acquis par le travail, parce que la contrainte physique, c'est le meilleur moyen d'acquérir l'auto-discipline.
L'auto-discipline, c'est ce qui vous permet de vous fixer des objectifs et de les tenir.
C'est-à-dire que c'est bien beau d'avoir des projets, c'est bien beau d'avoir des rêves, mais ces rêves
sont voués à ne rester que des chimères, tant qu'on ne met pas en oeuvre les moyens de les atteindre.
Et pendant des années, j'ai grandi avec l'idée qu'il fallait avoir des rêves, il fallait avoir des perspectives,
des espoirs... et que c'était ça le moteur de la vie. Mais en fait, ce n'est pas ça, le moteur de la vie.
Le moteur de la vie,
ce sont tous les rituels qu'on met en place pour atteindre ses objectifs.
Parce qu'il n'y a rien de plus gratifiant, il n'y a rien de plus satisfaisant, que d'atteindre un objectif qu'on s'est fixé.
Et cet objectif peut être totalement modeste, ça peut être un objectif qui paraît ridicule pour n'importe qui, mais qui aura du sens à nos yeux.
Et à partir du moment où ça a du sens à nos yeux, à partir du moment où ça a une valeur,
ça nous fait grandir. Ça donne du sens à notre vie, ça donne du sens à ce qu'on fait,
c'est ça qui fait que vous allez pouvoir vous lever de votre lit le matin, même s'il est 2 heures du matin,
même si vous avez dormi 1 heure et demi dans la nuit, mais c'est pas grave parce que vous savez que
au bout de cet effort,
il y a la concrétisation de votre projet.
Et ça, c'est surpuissant ! C'est pour ça que je dis à tous mes élèves
qui ont du mal à savoir comment s'orienter, à savoir ce qu'ils veulent faire dans la vie,
je leur dis simplement :
"Pense à ce qui te fait te lever le matin,
pense à ce qui te donne de l'énergie quand tu fais telle ou telle chose,
et dis-toi que c'est la seule chose qui compte. Le reste n'existe pas... le reste n'a pas d'importance !".
Peu importe ce que les gens vous diront, peu importe que les gens essaient de vous décourager, de vous démobiliser...
Personnellement, c'est ce qui m'est arrivé. Quand j'ai commencé à dire à mon entourage, à 18 ans,
"Je vais m'inscrire à la fac, je vais avoir un travail de nuit à temps partiel, je vais passer mon permis,
je vais prendre le train tous les matins pour aller à la fac",
les gens me regardaient en rigolant, en me disant "Mais, tu ne vas jamais tenir".
Et ils le disaient avec une intention qui n'était pas du tout malveillante. Ils le disaient comme ils le pensaient, si vous voulez.
Moi, je recevais ça
comme des injures. Ça sous-entendait : "Tu n'es pas capable de le faire !"
et ça, c'était presque un carburant, un stimulant pour moi.
Dans tous les cas, je savais que ce n'était pas ça qui allait m'empêcher de le faire,
parce que je l'avais décidé et parce qu'à partir du moment où on prend une décision,
on peut dire tout ce qu'on voudra autour de nous,
peu importe... ça ne compte pas !
On ne fait que ce qu'on a décidé de faire,
et ça ne sert à rien de forcer les gens, ou de vouloir forcer les gens à faire ce qu'ils n'ont pas décidé de faire.
Encouragez les gens à faire ce qu'ils ont décidé de faire. Et si ce qu'ils ont décidé
échoue, au moins vous n'aurez pas contribué à cet échec.
Dans tous les cas,
dites-vous bien une chose,
c'est que si on fait une erreur,
cette erreur nous servira. On doit aller au bout de nos erreurs. Ce n'est pas grave de faire des erreurs, mais le tout, c'est
de laisser la personne faire des erreurs...
avec bienveillance,
sans chercher à infléchir sa décision.
Laisser les gens faire ! Dites-vous bien une chose, c'est que si vous avez une conscience,
c'est que les autres ont une conscience également. Et quand les gens vous disent qu'ils vont faire quelque chose,
dites-vous bien qu'ils y ont réfléchi.
Arrêtez de vouloir expliquer aux gens ce qu'ils doivent penser, ou comment ils doivent vivre...
Ça ne marche pas ! Et tout ce qui risque de vous arriver, c'est que cette personne va vous démentir, cette personne
va vous prouver que vous avez eu tort.
Accompagnez les gens dans leurs projets, accompagnez les gens dans leurs
décisions, et vous verrez que vous n'aurez qu'à vous en féliciter.
Je ferme la parenthèse.
Quand toutes ces personnes ont... j'allais dire : "ont essayé de me dissuader",
ce n'est pas la réalité, elles n'ont pas essayé de me dissuader. Mais en tout cas, quand elles m'ont fait part
de leur point de vue, par rapport à ça, ça ne m'a pas du tout fait changer d'avis sur ce que je devais faire.
J'ai continué à suivre ma route, j'ai continué à faire ce que je croyais être juste,
et au final je n'ai eu, là encore,
qu'à m'en réjouir. Et je n'ai eu que de la gratification par rapport à ça,
parce que ça m'a permis d'évoluer, ça m'a permis de grandir, de devenir adulte beaucoup plus vite que si j'avais simplement suivi mes études
financées par papa maman.
Je peux vous dire que quand on paye de sa poche ses premières vacances
son premier voyage
avec sa petite amie,
on est obligé de faire attention à ce qu'on va dépenser.
On est obligé de
regarder les bonnes affaires pour prendre son billet train. Vous voyez, tout ce ce genre de petites choses
qui font la réalité de la vie d'un travailleur.
Tous ces petits détails qui font que on est obligé d'être conscient des choses, on est obligé
de savoir comment les choses se passent pour s'y adapter.
Parce que on peut pas faire ce qu'on veut quand on est dans cette situation.
Je dis souvent :
"Les gens pauvres, les travailleurs pauvres,
ne sont pas plus vertueux que les autres, mais ils ont la vertu de la contrainte".
La vertu de la contrainte, c'est la vertu qu'on acquiert par la contrainte.
Et le bon sens, le bon sens populaire, "le bon sens", cette expression que beaucoup de gens aiment dénigrer, c'est ça, le bon sens.
C'est de dire : "On ne peut pas tout faire, on ne peut pas faire tout et n'importe quoi,
on est obligé de prendre en compte les répercussions de nos actes, de nos décisions,
sur notre vie".
Et le travail
permet
de développer une conscience aiguë des conséquences de nos actes, des conséquences de nos choix,
et ça permet d'avoir une
compréhension du monde qu'on ne trouve pas dans les livres. Ça développe un rapport au travail très spécial,
et c'est ce rapport au travail que j'ai,
qui a ses avantages, mais qui a aussi ses inconvénients.
Je suis quelqu'un,
de très perfectionniste, je suis quelqu'un qui n'aime pas, qui ne supporte pas le travail bâclé, le travail mal fait.
Je déteste l'idée de faire quelque chose, simplement pour le faire.
Pour moi, une chose, si je la fais, je veux qu'elle soit bien faite.
Ça peut produire certains blocages,
c'est-à-dire par exemple, que là actuellement la vidéo que je suis en train de tourner,
depuis le début j'ai cette petite gêne de me dire que je n'ai pas préparé cette vidéo.
Donc je sais que je ne serai pas totalement satisfait,
et ça m'emmerde de mettre en ligne sur ma chaîne YouTube une vidéo dont je ne serai pas totalement satisfait.
Mais j'apprends, je travaille sur moi justement, j'apprends aussi à accepter l'imperfection.
Parce que
lorsqu'on se fixe des objectifs inatteignables,
c'est le meilleur moyen d'être dans une frustration et dans une immobilité permanente. Au bout d'un moment,
il faut accepter les défauts, il faut accepter l'imperfection, il faut accepter qu'on puisse
trouver que ce qu'on a fait, c'est de la merde.
C'est bon signe, ça veut dire qu'on a des axes de progression. Ça veut dire qu'on évolue.
La plupart des choses que j'ai pu faire jusqu'à aujourd'hui, quand je me retourne dessus, je me dis : "C'était nul",
mais en fait, ce n'était pas nul. Ce n'était pas nul, parce que c'est ce qui m'a permis de progresser, d'évoluer dans le bon sens.
Il est certain que tout ce que j'ai fait jusqu'à présent, m'a conduit à ce que je suis aujourd'hui.
Et sans aller jusqu'à dire que je suis fier de moi, fier de ce que je fais,
je dirais en tout cas que je n'en ai pas honte, que je les assume, que je le revendique.
Et après tout,
on n'a pas à
s'auto-dénigrer. On n'a pas à considérer que ce qu'on fait c'est nul, si on ne le pense pas.
J'ai la conviction que
le travail que je produis à travers cette chaîne YouTube : "Le Précepteur",
j'ai l'intime conviction que ce travail est utile.
D'un autre côté, à chaque fois que je revois une des vidéos que j'ai publiées sur la chaîne,
je vois tout ce qui ne va pas, je m'en veux, ça me dérange.
Mais je me dis : dans la balance,
il y a plus de positif que de négatif.
Et quand je vois vos commentaires, quand je vois les pouces en l'air que vous pouvez me laisser sur mes vidéos,
généralement j'ai à peu près 90% de pouce en l'air sur mes vidéos,
à ce moment-là, je me dis : "Charles, détends-toi !".
"Regarde...
et vois que ton travail est apprécié, il est estimé,
et ça suffit".
"Ne cherche pas à te fixer des objectifs inatteignables,
parce que c'est le meilleur moyen de souffrir. C'est le meilleur moyen d'être malheureux".
Aujourd'hui, j'ai pris la décision d'enregistrer une vidéo
beaucoup plus personnelle que mes vidéos habituelles, parce que,
étant donné que mon domaine, c'est la pédagogie,
il faut savoir que
l'acte de transmission,
ce qui est selon moi une assez bonne définition de ce qu'on fait dans la pédagogie,
l'acte de transmission, ça suppose un lien de proximité,
ça suppose un lien affectif
avec la personne qui est en face de nous. Et au bout d'un moment,
je ne peux pas
me présenter à vous sur une chaîne de pédagogie, sans vous dévoiler une partie de ce que je suis, une partie de ma personne.
Et même si...
ça me met un petit peu mal à l'aise de vous parler de moi,
j'estime que c'est quelque chose que je vous dois.
Et j'espère qu'en faisant ça, vous allez comprendre un petit peu mieux, peut-être,
le sens de ma démarche.
Le sens de ma démarche, c'est de vous dire :
"Vous avez entre vos mains un potentiel que vous ne soupçonnez même pas.
Chaque personne avec laquelle vous interagissez, vous pouvez éveiller en elle des choses extraordinaires."
J'ai rencontré énormément de personnes tout au long de ma vie,
qui m'ont
fait prendre conscience de certaines choses,
qui m'ont donné envie
de faire certaines choses,
et je me dis que sans ces rencontres,
je serai toujours
le Charles de 18 ans qui découvre la vie,
je n'aurais pas avancé, je n'aurais pas évolué.
Et aujourd'hui, je REMERCIE du plus profond de mon coeur,
TOUTES les personnes,
dont j'ai croisé le chemin,
et qui m'ont permis de me remettre en cause, qui m'ont permis de mieux comprendre certaines choses, qui m'ont permis de mieux accepter
certaines choses.
Et parmi ces choses, ce que je suis,
parce qu'en fait, toutes ces personnes m'ont transmis quelque chose. Et la transmission
ce n'est pas seulement ce que fait le professeur envers son élève.
La transmission, c'est tout ce qui se passe entre vous et l'autre, lorsque vous interagissez de manière sincère.
Et lorsque je dis "de manière sincère", ça veut dire :
sans considérer l'autre comme un concurrent, un rival,
un ennemi potentiel.
On peut
ne pas faire confiance à tout le monde, je le comprends très bien,
et je ne vais pas chercher à vous convaincre du contraire.
Mais par contre, on peut donner à l'autre le crédit de ses intentions.
Et donner à l'autre le crédit de ses intentions, c'est simplement se dire : "Cette personne qui est en face de moi,
si je fais bien les choses,
je vais éveiller chez elle quelque chose de bon, quelque chose de bon pour elle,
quelque chose de bon pour le groupe, et donc indirectement quelque chose de bon pour moi aussi".
Pensez à ça.
Vous avez ce pouvoir magique
d'interagir avec les autres de manière à faire émerger le meilleur en elle.
Je ne dis pas que ce que je fais sur ma chaîne YouTube
consiste à faire émerger le meilleur
qui est en chacun d'entre vous.
Mais je dis simplement que c'est une petite pierre à l'édifice,
dont j'espère qu'elle sera, peut-être, une petite source d'inspiration pour quelques internautes.
J'ai toujours du mal à parler devant une caméra, parce que pour moi, ce n'est pas naturel de parler à une machine.
Je vais essayer dorénavant de me dire que je ne parle pas une caméra mais que je parle à un être humain.
Et cet être humain,
je ne sais pas quel âge il a, je ne sais pas où ils habite, je ne sais pas ce qu'il fait dans la vie...
mais je sais que cet être humain, il a en lui quelque chose de bon que j'ai le pouvoir d'éveiller,
si je m'y prends bien.
Et j'aimerais
vous proposer de faire la même chose,
et j'aimerais vous demander, tout simplement,
de garder cela à l'esprit
lorsque vous interagissez avec les autres.
De garder ça à l'esprit lorsque vous allez poster un commentaire.
De garder ça à l'esprit lorsque
vous allez parler
à votre enfant, à votre frère, à votre sœur, à votre conjoint, à votre conjointe, à vos parents à vos voisins...
à toutes les personnes que vous côtoyez,
en vous disant que,
vous aussi, vous avez ce pouvoir de faire émerger le meilleur.
Et faire émerger le meilleur en l'autre, c'est un très bon moyen de faire émerger le meilleur en soi.
Et comme dirait l'autre : "C'est tout le mal que je vous souhaite".